bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour cette
première faq de la chaîne après plus
d'un an à vous proposer chaque mois une
nouvelle vidéo bien il est grand temps
de répondre à toutes les questions vous
m'avez posée alors c'est parti jusqu'à
l'ouverture de la chaîne j'étais
archéologues ce qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui et je vous expliquerai
pourquoi juste après j'ai un parcours
universitaire classique j'ai commencé
avec une licence en histoire de l'art et
archéologie
puis j'ai enchaîné avec un master
recherche en archéologie
je me suis spécialisé dans l'archéologie
sous marine en étudiant notamment la
navigation antiques en méditerranée donc
très concrètement j'étudiais les épave
découverte en méditerranée et à partir
du matériel qu'on avait retrouvé à bord
et bien j'essayais de comprendre d'où
venait le navire ce qu'il transportait
et qui étaient à bord donc c'était
passionnant et durant cet apprentissage
théorique et bien j'ai dû me former sur
le terrain donc d'aimer big mes études
je me suis inscrite à des chantiers
qu'on appelle des chantiers écoles qui
sont ceux organisés par les universités
qui vident vous apprendre les techniques
de fouilles grâce à ces chantiers d'un
j'ai appris notamment à piocher sans me
ruiner le dos et j'ai commencé sur des
sites qui étaient aux alentours de lyon
parce que lyon c'est la ville où j'ai
fait toutes mes études et où je vis à
l'heure actuelle mon premier chantier
c'était une villa gallo romaine et le
second celle des thermes gallo-romains
en isère
très vite à 20 ans j'ai su ce que je
voulais faire je voulais être
archéologue en hausse mara plongeuse
archéologues c'était un peu mon plan de
carrière durant cinq ans j'ai fouillé
fouillé fouillé et plonger plonger
plonger
j'ai enchaîné les stages du drassm qui
le département des recherches
archéologiques subaquatiques et sous
marines a marseille des contrats payer
tout ça en parallèle de mes études
et puis j'ai tout arrêté
il s'est passé c'est qu'à la suite du
masters j'ai voulu enchaîner avec une
thèse mais je n'ai pas trouvé de
financement et à la même époque je
terminais un chantier sur lequel j'étais
depuis trois ans et plutôt trois étés
consécutifs et je ne pourrai pas de
chantier pour continuer d'y des tsarines
thèse sans financement ça veut dire sans
laboratoire qui vous suit sans garantie
de trouver un travail à la fin et
surtout de dieu que seul un jury dire à
votre travail qui est un travail
vraiment comme ça ça m'a complètement
découragé c'était fin 2015 et je
commençais à regarder des chaînes de
vulgarisation scientifique et culturel
sur youtube qui émergeait et qui me
plaisait mais y'a un truc qui m'a frappé
il y avait aucune chaîne de
vulgarisation scientifique en
archéologie et en anthropologie et pour
les autres disciplines comme l'histoire
à y avait quasiment aucune femme donc en
tête la motivation elle est un film va
proposer un contenu scientifique en
archéologie en anthropologie et en
histoire et au final ça n'a pas été trop
difficile à mettre ça en place parce que
je me suis rendu compte que dans toutes
mes études j'avais lu les livres que je
les avais fiche et là j'ai pris des
notes et ses notes dans fait est
constitué des épisodes pré écrit il ya
des trucs à au début de la vidéo je vous
ai dit que j'étais archéologues de fait
je ne me suis plus parce que je ne
fouille plus et je ne participe plus à
la recherche scientifique je ne publie
pas d'articles ou de rapports de
fouilles
donc quand je me présente je dis que
j'ai une formation d'archéologues points
je précise parce que j'ai déjà vu dans
des articles qui parlent de la chaîne on
peut me présentait parfois en tant
qu'historienne mais je ne suis pas
historienne jettent archéologues je peux
le redevenir mais pour l'instant je suis
dédé est sur youtube
[Musique]
aujourd'hui la chaîne v et mon activité
principale c'est à dire que c'est ce à
quoi je consacre la totalité de mon
temps n'est pas une activité qui est
viable pour l'instant mais lorsque je
les lance et je me suis fixé comme
objectif qu'il génère de l'argent au
bout d'un an c'est importe la sones
jouer simplement voir si des personnes
étaient susceptibles de me soutenir
financièrement donc par exemple des
particuliers d'un tipi ou des
institutions culturelles comme les
musées ou des offices du tourisme et ça
a été le cas pratiquement un an jour
pour jour j'avais une première commande
de vidéos qui est la vidéo de ville qui
est une vidéo rémunérés qui faisait peut
être vu donc je n'ai aucune raison
d'arrêter la chaîne que j'ai toujours
envisagé d'ailleurs comme un projet sur
le long terme et d'ailleurs vous êtes
toujours plus nombreux à venir soutenir
sur tipis et ça ça confirme que j'ai
raison de vouloir continuer
grâce à tipis et outils peur que je
remercie infiniment viens j'ai pu
progresser et améliorer les vidéos
chaque mois pour vous donner une idée
les dons tic et ça m'a permis d'acquérir
deux panneaux led pour la lumière un
nouvel objectif et ça m'a aidé à
financer en partie l'achat d'un
micro-cravate fille qui est vraiment le
moyen de rendre la chaîne en partie
viable et vous proposer un contenu
toujours plus créatif et original
si vous voulez devenir tipper c'est très
facile et peu contraignants vous êtes
libre de choisir le montant de votre don
à partir d'un euro et de décider qui ce
don est régulier ou ponctuel vous
arrêter et vous recommencez
quand vous voulez vous trouverez le lien
d'un apache tipi sous la vidéo et sur la
page d'accueil de ma chaîne
ceci étant dit mais il faut le dire
parce que tipi ça fait partie des
projets de la chaîne et bien rentrons
dans le vif du sujet oui il y a des
projets que je veux mettre en place dès
la rentrée tout en continuant de publier
les épisodes classiques et bien le
challenge cette année c'est de vous
proposer des vidéos en collaboration
avec d'autres vidéaste alors je peux pas
vous donner les noms des chaînes avec
lesquels des choses sont prévues
ne vous inquiétez pas vous serez tenu au
courant en temps et en heure ensuite ce
que je souhaite le plus mettre en place
pour la chaîne ce sont des vidéos
tournées en extérieur
et petit plus à l'étranger il ya
tellement de sites archéologiques en
europe dont j'aimerais vous parler avec
de belles images que j'aurai réalisé moi
même pour vous donner une idée la vidéo
sur les menhirs qui est la vidéo la plus
vue de ma chaîne et bien c'est un format
que j'aimerais développer et d'ailleurs
là dans quelques mois je pars en italie
pour tourner un futur épisode
j'ai prévu de vous tourner un épisode
envers du décor type blog pour vous
expliquer toutes les phases de
recherches pour un épisode les phases
d'écriture est aussi de vous montrer
comment je monte mon studio de tournage
donc sans rentrer dans les détails je
peux déjà vous dire que je tourne avec
un g h2 qui fait ma foi bien sr même si
j'aimerais en changer dès que possible
avec un objectif 50 mm de chèques en
collard qui est un des objectifs
d'équipés de très belles dunes âge et
pour le montage j'utilise la suite adobe
donc première procès c'est 2015 et pour
le traitement du son j'essaye de me
dépatouiller avec audition mais c'est un
petit peu compliqué c'est un peu du
bricolage
ce que je fais pour longtemps et
d'ailleurs c'est l'un des objectifs pour
cette fin d'année c'est me former un peu
plus sérieusement à la suite adobe vient
de répondre aux questions les plus
récurrentes et très générales sont
profilées l'histoire de la chaîne mais
évidemment il ya plein de questions vous
m'avez posé que j'ai pas pu ranger dans
une thématique précise
donc avant de se quitter on va sentir
quelques unes et pour cela je prends mon
téléphone et je vais vous lire les
questions ce sera beaucoup plus simple
doute est venu ta passion pour
l'archéologie
alors c'est une question qui est très
récurrentes et qui est d'ailleurs la
question qu'on pose à tous les
archéologues qui me fait souvent sourire
parce que c'est oublier que
l'archéologie
c'est avant tout un métier qui peut être
contraignant et qui est pas toujours
passionnant c'est un métier qui consiste
en grande partie à passer son temps du
biotech parfois devant un tableau excel
à rentrer des données sur les coprolithe
issu d'un abri sous roche dans le
vercors par exemple et que préside ce
sont des excréments fossilisés et donc
vous pouvez être archéologue et
spécialiste des crottes de mouton ou de
chèvre fossilisés et ces gens sont
d'ailleurs très utiles à la recherche
scientifique
c'est un métier contraignant parce que
ça demande va une grande mobilité vous
êtes rarement chez vous quand vous êtes
en fouille ça demande aussi une capacité
à pouvoir vivre et travailler en groupe
et ça c'est pas forcément évident et
aussi ça demande une très bonne
condition physique parce que
l'archéologie c'est rarement au pinceau
en deçà de passe mais plus souvent à la
pioche donc oublier complètement indiana
jones et
lara croft donc nous concernant mon
intérêt pour l'archéologie il est venu
petit à petit durant les premières
années de fac
en fait j'avais la liste des cours
qu'ont proposé et je choisissais des
cours en archéologie
as-tu voyager oui et d'ailleurs certains
de ces voyages ont sans doute influencé
mon choix pour mes études j'ai voyagé en
italie d'ailleurs à 10 ans j'ai
découvert rome
et ça ça m'a vraiment marqué et puis
ensuite il ya eu des voyages au pérou en
egypte est très récemment au mexique
d'ailleurs si des photos des lieux que
je visite vous intéresse ou vous
plaisent n'hésitez pas à me suivre sur
instagram je poste régulièrement des
photos des deux visites dessus quelle
est ta plus belle découverte
alors j'ai pas là je suis désolé on
aurait pas de trésor j'ai pas découvert
de d'objets merveilleux les plus belles
découvertes sont plutôt des bons moments
durant en chantier il est donc là la
première chose qui me reviennent
c'était d'ailleurs durant un chantier
école donc première expérience de
fouilles j'étais avec une copine et ont
pioché comme des dingues pour simplement
descendre de niveau donc ont creusé un
trou et on dégageait des sceaux de
pierre journée entière on a dégagé des
grosses pierres c'était vraiment d'hugo
gros oeuvre et puis d'un coup on est
tombé sur une dalle de marbre sur nos
pieds sous nos pieds pardon et on a
juste voulu bas commencé à la dégager
pour en atteindre les limites
en fait on a dégagé un long moment et
s'est trouvé que on avait deux compris
qu'on était en fait dans des termes des
thermes romains et on avait donc les
pieds dans une piscine en marbre et ça
c'était plutôt cool
et quand je dis cool je pèse mes mots
d'ailleurs parce que quand il fait 30
degrés goût fouillé
la libye vous êtes bien content d'être
en chaussettes sur du marbre
quelle est ta période préférée la
préhistoire et le néolithique
alors que je ne suis pas spécialiste de
cette période mais l'idée de savoir que
néolithique c'est une révolution majeure
dont dépendons encore pour beaucoup de
choses l'agriculture notamment
eh bien ça me paraît primordial
d'aborder cette période et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je consacre
beaucoup de temps dans mes vidéos à en
parler quelle question aimerais tu qu'on
te pose à pourquoi la chaîne s'appelle
pas ces sauvages parce que des fois
j'entends assas et non de youtube 2 où
j'ai déjà lu ça fait nom de rappeur
alors ça me fait rire parce que le nom
de la chaîne il n'est pas anodin il a un
réel sens pas assez sauvage ça fait
référence à un livre qui a écrit claude
lévi strauss qui est un anthropologue
assez connus qui s'appelle la pensée
sauvage et non pas la pensée des
sauvages
c'est un ouvrage fondateur qui prend le
parti de déconstruire les stéréotypes
sur les sociétés qu'on appelle des
sociétés primitives et c'est un petit
peu mon objectif sur la chaîne parce
qu'on considérait que ces sociétés
visées comme des hommes des cavernes et
si vous connaissez la chaîne et que vous
avez vu quelques-unes de mes vidéos vous
savez que les hommes des cavernes
ça n'existe pas personne n'a jamais vécu
au fond d'une grotte dans l'humidité et
l'obscurité
c'est impossible crois-tu aux gens qui
mangent du tram a autant que je crois au
géobiologue quel âge as-tu 27 ans et mon
premier cheveu blanc ce matin yannick
commente informe qu avec des livres
alors ensuite une question un petit peu
plus longue
on parle dans cuir au néolithique avec
les notions de richesses et de
sédentarisation cette forme de
communauté et vite c'est elle au
paléolithique si oui sous quelle forme
alors je suis déjà pas d'accord avec
l'idée d'en cueillir au néolithique
parce que la notion dampierre c'est une
notion floue et très débattu et celui
qui en donnent la meilleure définition
c'est jean tulard qu'il y ait un
historien spécialiste du premier empire
et de napoléon qui donne donc un critère
pour parler dans pire je vais vous
donner ces cinq critères le premier
critère
une volonté d'extension c'est le concept
même d'impérialisme le second critère
c'est une organisation centralisée
donc il faut qu'il y ait une capitale et
un chef qui impose sa volonté à tous il
faut ensuite que les peuples soient
encadrés par une politique économique et
fiscale commune
il faut qu'il y ait une croyance en une
supériorité des sens et le dernier
critère il faut qu'il y ait un début et
une fin
clairement identifiés et on n'a
clairement pas assez donné pour la
préhistoire
désolé deschênes a conseillé alors si
vous cherchez des chaînes de
vulgarisation scientifique peu connue
pour certaines avec un bon bagage
scientifique
allez faire un tour sur le blog du café
des sciences dont je fais partie depuis
peu qui tient un bon répertoire classés
par discipline donc vous avez du choix
c'est très bien fait et vous avez
surtout la garantie qu on vous racontera
pas de bêtises on arrive à la fin des
questions des livres pour démarrer en
archéologie ou en anthropologie
oui il y en a je vous les présente
rapidement et je vous mettrai toutes les
références en barre d'infos pour
l'archéologie vous pouvez partir sur
l'archéologie devant l'imposture de jean
pierre adam qui est un très bon ouvrage
pour détruire toutes les théories
farfelues
par exemple les théories aliens tout ce
qui peut se dire d'un foncé sur la
construction des pyramides
par exemple les adeptes de mythologie
grecque commencer par les ouvrages de
jean pierre vernant et le très connu
l'univers les dieux et les hommes pour
ceux qui souhaitent comprendre les
métiers d'archéologie des techniques de
fouille des ouvrages très pratiques ont
publié dans la collection la découverte
en partenariat avec l'inrap l'inrap
c'est l'institut national de recherche
en archéologie préventive pour
l'anthropologie prenait comme base le
livre de claude lévi-strauss race et
histoire cours accessibles et qui est
une bonne manière pour appréhender la
diversité culturelle et la complexité de
notre monde occidental toujours en
anthropologie un bon exemple de récits
de terrain c'est chronique des indiens
guayaquil par pierre 4 enfin pour les
plus motivés je vous conseille vivement
la ds et le grain d' alain testart qui
est un livre qui mêle archéologie et
anthropologie et qui
analyse les symboles et les religions
préhistorique
c'est un ouvrage qui renverse
complètement les commentaires habituels
qu'on peut lire sur ces questions est
vraiment dans ce type d'ouvragé tout est
bon à prendre
ce ne sont que des conseils et si des
vidéos plus poussée qui prône une
lecture vous intéresse doute le mans en
commentaire et j'y réfléchirai allez une
dernière avant de se quitter et pas des
moindres c'est quoi l'anthropologie
alors l'anthropologie ça veut tout dire
et rien dire
c'est l'étude de l'homme sous tous ses
aspects le social le culturel le
religieux en fait ce qui distingue le
plus l'anthropologie des autres sciences
de l'homme qui ont aussi cette
prétention englobante c'est avant tout
une démarche une démarche qu'on peut
résumer avec l'expression observation
participante
ça signifie de s'immerger dans un
terrain et de passer beaucoup de temps
dans une société pour en cerner le plus
best est possible
l'archéologue il s'occupe du passé il
étudie l'homme à partir des vestiges
matériels tandis que l'anthropologue il
travaille à partir de toutes les
productions d'une société dans le
présent les redskins les rites
l'artisanat l'architecturé etc etc
on confond souvent des ternes et nos
grâce ethnologues anthropologues et
c'est normal en fait ça constitue trois
phases de l'étude
la première étude quand vous arrivez sur
un terrain et bien vous compilez laisser
tout ce que vous voyez n'y prenez des
notes
ça s'appelle l'ethnographie et vous
retrouver le mot graphique de l'écriture
en rythme grâce ensuite vous changer
d'échelle vous faites de l'ethnologie
c'est à dire que vous allez comparer
l'effet d'une société à l'autre et là
vous faites de l'ethnologie et ensuite
vous changer en créant des chaînes là on
passe à l'échelle de l'homme une vision
beaucoup plus globale et ça s'appelle
l'anthropologie c'est tout pour cette
fois-ci et merci à tous d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo et j'espère qu'elle a
répondu à vos questions
je ne le fais pas à chaque cinq vidéos
met donc là j'en profite pour vous
inviter à venir me suivre sur les
réseaux sociaux et à venir cliquez sur
la petite cloche situé sous la vidéo
pour être tenu au courant des sorties
vidéo est aussi je vous invite à venir
jeter un oeil sur ma page typique
je vous remercie tout les tous d'être
grâce à vous je peux produire un contenu
qui me plaît dans un cadre agréable
c'est à dire avec une belle communauté
pour recevoir ce travail et je vais tout
faire pour continuer ça le plus
longtemps possible
on se retrouve dès septembre pour la
reprise des épisodes habituel d'ici là
passez une belle fin d'été à bientôt
on se retrouve dès septembre ah ah
il faut que j'arrête de manger jarghoun
j'ai faim
[Musique]
j'ai très très très très présent
on
non
demont
[Musique]